just because things aren't going the way
you want them to now
doesn't mean that things won't get
better in the future and you have to
trust
that the dots will align somewhere in
your future even if it doesn't make
sense
right now for your business hi i'm evan
carmichael i believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help
and today i'm answering a question from
one of my readers pedro
he responded to my newsletter and one of
my newsletters i posted a quote
that said don't confuse your path with
your destination
just because it's stormy now doesn't
mean you aren't headed for sunshine
and ho pedro wrote back to say what are
the signs that mean we're headed for
sunshine
how do i know great question pedro
how you know that you're on the right
path
is you feel it in your heart that you
love what you're doing
you love what you're doing and it feels
right
and a lot of the best entrepreneurs in
the world the most famous entrepreneurs
in the world when they first started
everything seemed to not make sense it
wasn't the logical thing to do
but they did it because it felt right
when
steve jobs started apple
he dropped out of university he dropped
out of university to start hanging out
with computer geeks
and people said steve you're crazy like
what are you doing why are you dropping
out of college
and what are you doing hanging out with
guys who are trying to build a computer
nobody needs a personal computer they're
only for big businesses
this is crazy go back to school go get a
job
could you imagine if steve jobs went and
did that
he didn't know how things would work out
but he did it because he was trusting
his gut and he was following heart his
heart and it felt right
if you feel like what you're doing is
right
and you're helping people and it makes
you feel good
you have to keep going even if you end
up having to take a part-time job to
survive
or a full-time job and do this on the
side you have to find a way to keep
going
if you're passionate about it if you
love doing it if you get excited by the
thought of doing it and
you're actually in it and you love it
you have to keep going
if you lose the love if it stops
becoming interesting
and exciting for you then it might just
be stormy ahead
okay the sunshine might not be there
because you have to push through
every entrepreneur has to push through
it's not easy okay
no entrepreneur has it handed to them
you have to bust through
the darkest days the days when you think
that this is never going to work you
have to get up the next day and go work
again
and eventually the clouds do clear
and you hit your success but it's not
without a lot of hard work it's not
without a lot of suffering
and it will only happen if you
absolutely love what you're doing
another quick story for you is one of
milton hershey i love this story
when he started his business he's from
the hershey chocolate company
he borrowed some money from his aunt to
start his business a couple hundred
dollars
in philadelphia and he was making
caramels and he worked 15 16 hours a day
and he he made the caramels overnight
and he sold him on the streets during
the day
the business failed in philadelphia so
he moved it to chicago and new orleans
and new york
and it failed in all three cities as
well so we've had four failures now
and in new york he failed when
kids on the street came and they robbed
him they took all his money to call his
supplies and he had to return home to
philadelphia
broke with nothing then his family
disowns him they say hershey you're a
failure you're not part of this family
we don't want to know you
so we had to go live with his former
employee
who took him in so he can get started
again and what did he do he went back to
business
and he started making chocolates and
eventually built up a huge company that
had a massive
impact hershey it's a great story if you
read it and the impact he had in his
community
but he had to go through such crap
more than most people would you go
through
years of failure years of working
16 hours a day failing four times with
your business having your family disown
you
the only thing that gets you through all
that is feeling like you're doing the
right thing
feeling like you have to keep going
because you love what you're doing
it's having an impact and you're doing
the right thing
even though all logic says go in the
other direction
why are you doing this hershey why do
you keep doing this to yourself you're
never gonna make it this is a bad idea
why did he keep going because he loved
it because he felt he had to keep going
because he felt he owed it to himself
and to his community to keep doing it
and eventually he hit success now it
doesn't have to be that hard for you but
it might be that hard
and unless you love what you're doing to
your core
you're gonna quit when it gets too hard
if you don't love what you're doing to
your core
you will not achieve success with your
business
that's how you know if sunny skies
are ahead for you or if it's just a
whole storm ahead
good luck for those of you watching you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below makes me want to do more for
you
and i want to hear what you have to
think please leave a comment under this
video let me know what you think
ask me a question for your business and
i'll make a video reply for you thank
you so much and i'll see you on the next
episode